the Supreme Court is about to decide do
you have to pay union dues if your
workplace is unionized when I worked at
CBS and ABC I had to I was told this is
a union shop you must pay up
but now the court may say for government
workers that's unconstitutional so
unions are nervous if we lose this case
the entire public sector will be right
to work right-to-work would mean unions
could no longer force workers to join
and pay dues the union's values are all
money teacher Rebecca Friedreich's filed
a lawsuit that went to the Supreme Court
because she says unions are bullies you
understand why she says that when you
listen to some union leaders speak that
guy is boss of the biggest teachers
unions Rebecca got mad at her Union
during the last recession when she tried
to save some teachers jobs by getting
all the teachers to take a slight pay
cut they were willing to take a cut
absolutely we're willing to have that
discussion and all of America was taking
a pay cut pretty much why should we be
any different but the union wouldn't
even allow her to survey the other
teachers they said absolutely not would
not let me send out that survey then
angering her further they told me
Rebecca don't worry about those teachers
who are going to lose their jobs the
union's going to take care of them we're
going to give them a seminar on how to
get unemployment benefits so Rebecca
decided she no longer wanted to pay
union dues she sued the California
Teachers Association and after three
years the Supreme Court heard her case
[Applause]
Union voices were heard too they
protested on the steps outside the court
they were worried because supreme court
Watchers said Rebecca was likely to win
the case that has the potential to
decimate the way that public sector
unions function but then Supreme Court
Justice Antonin Scalia has died that was
the most
a stating day without Scalia's vote the
court deadlocked
that meant unions could continue forcing
teachers to pay dues it is a huge win
for public sector unions but now a new
case filed by this government worker
mark Janice is about to be heard by the
court with Neel Gorsuch the ninth
justice unions are so worried they even
agreed to speak to me our members want
their union they want their union to
have power
Steve Kreisberg represents the union
that's being sued by mark Janice it's
his right to dissent and not be a member
of our union he only has to pay the fees
that are used to her what's the point in
that if you have to pay that's the main
reasoning doesn't want to join he
doesn't want to be forced to pay for
something he doesn't agree with well I'm
not sure if he doesn't agree with it or
if he just simply doesn't want to pay
because you'd like to get those services
for free the union could say we're
bargaining for all you teachers if you
don't join the union you're a free rider
I never asked for their representation
all right but you're getting it
presumably benefited if I saw their
representation as a benefit then I could
agree with that but I don't see it as a
benefit their benefits aren't worth the
moral costs to me that sounds like the
words or right wing activists not the
words of a teacher she was a teacher who
got together with other teachers and
said let's take a pay cut so nobody has
to get fired and the union said no you
may not even put that to a vote they
elected somebody else so she has no more
right to call a vote then Hillary
Clinton has the right to conduct foreign
policy of the United States of America
Thomas Jefferson believed that to compel
a man to contribute to propagation of
opinions to which he disbelieves is
sinful and tyrannical Thomas Jefferson
had no sense of 21st century labor
relations though he probably didn't now
the Supreme Court will decide oral
arguments are scheduled for Monday the
court will announce its decision
sometime this summer I hope they'll see
it the way Jefferson did forcing someone
to pay for something they don't want is
tyranny
you